hey this is presh talwalkar
with your eyes closed you roll a pair of
dice
the casino dealer announces that at
least one of the roles is a one
what is the probability that both rolls
show a one
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
the surprising result is the probability
is not one-sixth
imagine the casino offered this game
with stakes
if you thought the probability was
one-sixth then you would be willing to
offer a one dollar bet for a six dollar
payout that both dice were showing a one
you would think this is a fair game but
in fact you would be losing money on
average the casino should actually be
offering an 11 payout for this to be a
fair game
the probability that both dice are
showing a one is actually much lower
let's calculate this
when you roll a pair of dice there are
36 equally likely outcomes each die can
show a number between one and six this
creates 36 different pairs
when the casino dealer announces that at
least one dice is showing a 1
we need to eliminate all the different
pairs which do not include a 1.
let's count the number of pairs which do
include a one
there are 11 different pairs and these
are equally likely roles to happen
now in 10 of these events one of the
dice is showing a one and the other dice
is not a one
in exactly one of the cases
both of the dice are showing a one
therefore there is a one in 11 chance or
about a 9.1 percent probability that
both dice are showing a 1.
this is a surprising result
and to give further evidence of this
we're going to do a numerical simulation
in a spreadsheet
we're going to set up a spreadsheet in
which we do a numerical estimation of
the probability
we imagine rolling two dice labeled a
and b
our sample space is the number of trials
in which at least one dice is showing a
one
a success in our experiment is a case in
which both dice are showing a one
to roll a dice in a spreadsheet we use
the function randbetween and we generate
a random number between one and six
our sample space is the number of trials
in which at least one roll is showing a
one
so we're going to set up a formula that
at least one roll has to be equal to one
then we'll allow it in our sample space
count it with the one otherwise we'll
count it as a zero
now we wanna see
a success in which both dice are showing
a one
so if this both dice are showing a one
we're going to count that as a success
otherwise we exclude it
so this is one roll of the dice neither
of them showed a one
so we can copy these formulas down
and eventually we'll get to a case in
which one of the dice is showing a 1.
so this formula calculates that yes
we're going to count this in our sample
space
now to get an accurate representation of
the probability we're going to want to
copy this down many many times
eventually we'll get to a case in which
both dice are showing the one
so i'm going to copy this down and we're
going to imagine doing 10 000 rolls
so now we can count the number of times
in which at least one dice is showing a
one
this will be the sum of the third column
this is about three thousand out of the
ten thousand rolls
and notice this is approximately 30
which is about the 11 over 36 that i was
saying were equally likely events
we now want to know the proportion of
these cases in which both roles are
showing a one
this will be the sum of the successes in
the fourth column
this is about 270.
so now we can calculate the probability
that both roles are one given at least 1
is a 1 as the ratio of the successes
divided by the number of sample space
now this is nearly 9
and this is roughly equal to the
probability we calculated of 1 divided
by 11. so this again justifies
that 1 over 11 is the correct
probability
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video please subscribe to
my channel i make videos on math and
game theory you can catch me on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on facebook google plus and patreon you
can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description